Німеччина не виключає постачання важких бойових танків Leopard,
щоб підтримати українські війська у майбутньому.
Про це заявив віцеканцлер ФРН Роберт Габек в інтерв'ю одному з німецьких телеканалів.
Коли настане це "майбутнє", щоправда, невідомо. Але зміна тональності свідчить
про позитивні зрушення в німецькому уряді, кажуть експерти.
Напередодні Різдва Франція, США і Німеччина пообіцяли Україні нові
поставки бронетехніки. Зокрема, 40 бойових машин піхоти Marder до кінця цього кварталу.
Мені здається, що в нинішньому випадку з "Мардером" рішення,
прийняті Сполученими Штатами Америки щодо поставки "Бредлі",
і рішення Франції щодо поставки розвідувальних танків вплинули на німецьке мислення.
Тому я вважаю важливим, щоб не лише Україна, а й інші партнери України
продовжували підштовхувати уряд Німеччини до перегляду своєї позиції
та прийняття спільних рішень.
Тож яку бронетехніку вже пообіцяв Захід і як вона може змінити хід війни?
Це два в одному: і танк, і гармата на колесах. Цю бронемашину
використовують в основному для бойової розвідки. Вона надзвичайно мобільна і тиха.
Ось на якій швидкості несеться AMX-10 RC.
Завдяки колісному приводу та малій вазі цей повнопривідний
розвідувальний танк розганяється до 85 кілометрів на годину
та може пересуватися на відстані до 800 кілометрів.
Це вдвічі далі звичайних гусеничних танків.
При цьому він має доволі потужну 105-мм гармату.
AMX-10 RC навряд чи матиме шанси проти звичайних танків - броня значно слабша,
але протистояти їм і не входить в його завдання.
16-тонний танк на колесах обслуговує екіпаж з чотирьох осіб.
Його розробили ще у 1970-ті роки. AMX-10 RC добре себе зарекомендував
під час виконання бойових місій у Чаді, Іраку, Косові, Афганістані та Малі.
Сполучені Штати нададуть Україні бойові машини піхоти Bradley M2.
Машина озброєна 25-мм автоматичною гарматою і кулеметом,
а також кількома бронебійними керованими ракетами.
Bradley M2 розрахована на підрозділ з дев'ятьох-десятьох військових,
може переміщатися водою на глибині до одного метра двадцяти сантиметрів
і рухатися зі швидкістю до 65 кілометрів на годину. Його також можна перевозити
важкими транспортними літаками. Bradley M2 разом зі стандартними
американськими основними бойовими танками М1 Abrams, які Київ також сподівається
отримати, призначені для протистояння танкам та піхоті противника.
Abrams завдяки кращій броні та міцнішому озброєнню йде попереду,
а Bradley забезпечує фланговий захист. Його випускають з 1980-их років
і він став одним із найбільш масових бронетранспортерів у світі.
Bradley використовували у всіх великих військових операціях США,
включаючи війну в Перській затоці 1991 року та війну в Іраку 2003 року.
Це бойова машина піхоти, яка забезпечує доставку піхоти та вогневу підтримку.
Marder може вмістити у собі 6-7 бійців. Він оснащений 20-міліметровою
автоматичною гарматою, а також опціонально керованими ракетами проти
наземних і повітряних цілей. Завдяки водолазній гідравліці може рухатися
крізь воду глибиною до двох метрів. На озброєння Marder прийняли ще в 1971 році.
Модель Puma, яка мала прийти на зміну, виявилася досі настільки проблемною,
що наразі не може замінити Marder.
Та чи вплине постачання цієї західної бронетехніки на перебіг війни в Україні?
Якщо поглянути на цифри, а США надають близько пів сотні Bradley,
Німеччина - близько 40 Marder, це не та чисельність, яка потрібна Україні.
Тобто кількість змін не принесе. Але це перші броньовані бойові машини,
які надходять від Заходу. Тож, гадаю, ця зміна важлива сама по собі.
Усе залежатиме від того, де Україна застосовуватиме ці машини.
Найімовірніше на певних відрізках лінії фронту, на яких точаться запеклі бої
і де вони дійсно можуть щось змінити.
"Мардерами" планується оснастити один батальйон ЗСУ, навчатимуть українців у Німеччині.
Експерти зазначають: ця техніка не нова - на озброєнні Бундесверу "Мардери"
стоять уже пів століття, - але перевірена. Її захисні характеристики
багато в чому перевершують радянські аналоги,
які активно використовуються на війні Росії проти України.
Що змінилося? Чому саме зараз Німеччина зважилася на постачання БМП?
Досі канцлер ФРН постійно наголошував, що Берлін не постачатиме нічого,
не узгодивши попередньо свої дії з партнерами.
Тож обіцянки поставок від Еммануеля Макрона і Джо Байдена, вочевидь,
стали саме тим сигналом, якого чекали в Берліні.
Офіційно ж в уряді ФРН обґрунтовують своє рішення цілою низкою факторів.
Мовляв, закінчуються запаси радянської техніки, яку можна передати Україні,
очікується розширення бойових дій навесні, та й обстріли інфраструктури
також вплинули на ухвалення цього рішення.
Критики ж називають згоду на постачання "Мардерів" запізнілою,
адже, за їхніми словами, більш ранні поставки врятували б чимало життів українців
і країна могла б звільнити на цей момент більше територій.
На тлі рішення щодо БМП "Мардер" дедалі голоснішими стають голоси тих,
хто вимагає поставити Україні важкі бойові танки. Саме ця техніка потрібна
українцям для прориву на фронті та повернення територій.
За відправку танків "Леопард" виступають вже
високопоставлені представники правлячої коаліції.
Партнери по коаліції з Вільної демократичної партії згодні з цим, хоч і нагадують:
подібний крок вимагає узгодження з партнерами по НАТО.
Активно виступають за постачання танків Україні і в опозиційному блоці ХДС/ХСС.
На думку оглядачів, разом із дискусією про постачання важких танків
у наступні місяці може бути порушено питання і про постачання бойових винищувачів.
Що швидше Україна матиме ці види озброєння, то раніше зможе закінчити війну,
вигнавши російські війська зі своєї території, стверджують експерти.
Територія України - це степ, особливо на півдні. Для того, щоб досягти прориву
на фронті, щоб витіснити росіян з української території, потрібно
створити механізовану силу, особливо проти супротивника, який має
дуже сильну артилерію. Ось чому для цього поштовху потрібна
комбінація основних бойових танків і бойових машин піхоти.
Нині Україна воює здебільшого радянськими танками Т-72,
а також їхніми модернізованими версіями, які надали Польща та Словаччина.
Але сучасні бойові танки, зокрема німецькі Leopard 2 та американські Abrams,
мають значно вищі тактико-технічні характеристики і могли б суттєво змінити
ситуацію на користь України. Експерти оптимістично налаштовані,
що в майбутніх дискусіях буде прийнято рішення поставити в Україну ще й бойові танки.
Уряд Німеччини ще кілька днів тому мав позицію не постачати
сучасні бойові машини піхоти, але зараз ухвалено рішення про їхню поставку.
Тож навіть якщо є позиція поки що не постачати танки "Леопард-2",
не виключено, що таке рішення ухвалять в майбутньому.
І я вважаю, що важливо завжди зосереджуватися на військовій ситуації,
на передовій в Україні та чітко пояснювати, що необхідно з суто військової точки зору.
І я стверджую, що з військової точки зору будуть необхідні основні бойові танки.
Leopard 2 оснащений 120-мм гарматою, яка дозволяє на ходу атакувати
нерухомі або рухомі цілі. Цей танк вагою 60 тонн і потужністю 1500 кінських сил
перебуває на озброєнні багатьох армій світу і довів свою ефективність
в операціях в Афганістані, перш за все через високий рівень захисту від атак.